It's safe to say that Hermione Granger and
Ron Weasley have always been the endgame
in the "Harry Potter" universe. Both of these
Gryffindors are beloved fantasy characters,
and they’ve always been favorably shipped
together. However, one particular scene
revolving around the two characters' relationship
wasn't quite as romantic. In "Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets," Emma Watson was quite
nervous to film a particular scene as Hermione…
and apparently angry with the movie's director
Chris Columbus for making her do it anyway.
There's a particular scene at the
end of the film in which Hermione
has to run into the Great Hall and hug
both Harry and Ron. However, the shy,
then-11-year-old Watson was too embarrassed to hug
both of the boys in front of the cast and crew.
Columbus tried to work around things
by making Watson hug Daniel Radcliffe
and shake Rupert Grint's hand instead. Watson was
even embarrassed to hug Radcliffe for too long,
so their hug had to be frozen for a
few seconds longer than it actually was
for it to appear more realistic on-screen. The
actress has since opened up on Instagram about
how nerve-wracking it was to film that
scene with everybody on set watching.
Watson even said that her arms
barely touched around his neck.
“You laugh, but this is actually
quite traumatic for me.”
The result of the scene actually ended
up working perfectly for the storyline
of Ron and Hermione. The fans of the
"Harry Potter" books and films know
of the underlying feelings that both
characters have for each other. Hermione
even ends up marrying the endearing redhead at the
conclusion of the series. If you're a true fan,
you're up to speed on everything that
happens throughout their relationship.
Adapting books into movies can be
extremely challenging, and many
details are often altered in the process.
Despite some of the major changes that had
to be made to fit within the restrictions
of filming the second "Harry Potter" movie,
"Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets" still holds up today.
Watson, Grint, and Radcliffe definitely grew
closer over the years as the movie franchise
went on. However, it seems like the actress's
attitude towards filming more intimate scenes with
her co-stars never changed. In "Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows: Part 1," one of the Horcruxes
shows Ron a vision of one of his biggest fears. It
just so happens to be Hermione and Harry kissing.
The vision is strange and intense, and Watson and
Radcliffe had to make it look really passionate.
Speaking with “The Seattle Times,”
Watson said that the experience
filming the kiss with Radcliffe was,
quote, "bloody awkward,” explaining,
“Dan and I are like brother and sister."
But, unlike her younger self,
she put her all into the scene,
following director David Yates's directions
with the hope that it might help them finish
filming more quickly. As the scene is
supposed to be a vision seen by Ron,
Grint was originally on set to watch them kiss
and give accurate reactions. But apparently,
Grint couldn't control his emotions at seeing
his two best friends making out. Grint Shared,
"Emma sent me out because I kept
laughing. It just looked really strange."
This scene is definitely more hands-on
than the "Chamber of Secrets" hug,
and Watson held it all together to get
the filming done. It wasn't even the
only kissing scene she had to do for the
franchise. Ron and Hermione finally make
their romance official with a kiss in "Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows: Part 2."
Being as close to Grint as she is with
Radcliffe, Watson told “Movies Ireland,”
"Believe me, we both wanted it to be
over equally as much as the other.
It's honestly like kissing
my brother. It was weird."
Despite how they felt in real life, the
kiss is a very important moment for Ron
and Hermione's relationship on-screen. Thankfully,
the two actors successfully overcame the
awkwardness to make it look realistic.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.